so jordan you were speaking a moment ago
about the the sort of lack of meaning
that people are looking for particularly
young men and it really is a a
big thing that young men seem to have
lost meaning post-modernism
killed the the scientific rationalist
world and the post-modernists have
decided to substitute for that a certain
utopian vision of the remolding of
american society
in in terms of what they call equity but
really amounts to tribal dynamics
and you see this over and over the
radical left pushing its own version of
utopianism
classical liberals have been
wrong-footed i think by
the need for something more fulfilling
which is why classical liberalism
always relied on an unspoken assumption
that you were going to find meaning in
your family you were going to find
meaning in religious community you were
going to find meaning
in bettering your social life outside of
government but when that unspoken
understanding just dissipated when when
religion started to to fall apart
all that was left was well let's just be
rational with one another there's not
much inspiring there and i think that's
why you see
that across the board a drive toward
irrationalism
a certain level of romanticism
dominating the society to the point
where irrationalism is much more prized
than rationalism if you make a rational
point if you cite data very often this
is now considered not only in politic
but but damaging and dangerous the other
thing that
that ideology does and the the radical
leftists are all
also very good at this is that it
provides you with a local a convenient
local for the
for the uh existence of evil
and so if you reflexively identify the
patriarchy with evil
well first of all that's a powerful idea
it's it
independent of its broad merit it's a
it's true now it's not the only truth
and it's not the complete
truth but it's true the reason it's true
is because
every hierarchical system hierarchical
system
degenerates tends to degenerate in the
direction of power
and all hierarchical systems are
less than they could be and that's
partly because
of the possibility that power and deceit
will corrupt them
but also partly because we're willfully
blind and
deceitful in our own personal lives and
so when you tell young people that
the cause of the trouble they see around
them in the world and maybe even the
disquiet in their own heart is the
malevolent
inadequacy of their society
that rings true and they don't hear the
rest of the story you know
and it's the rest of the story that i've
been trying to tell they don't hear
the story that yeah don't forget about
the evil and corruption that exists in
your own heart
and don't forget about the fact that
nature
this wondrous goddess as portrayed by
the anti-human
environmentalists and i by that i don't
mean all environmentalists by the way
that wonderful goddess nature is also
trying to
make you ill and kill you at all times
and so
but the story that corruption exists in
hierarchical structure
and that that's a consequence of
malevolence
the malevolent use of power and deceit
that's true
so it's very motivating especially if
you're young and you're looking for an
adventure now it's also
too convenient which is one of its
tremendous dangers because
unless you're taught to look within and
identify the malevolence there
as the primary moral obligation
then you now have an excuse and a moral
justification to take out all of your
negative emotion your hostility your
resentment
everything about you that's unexamined
on
the demonic enemy and of course that's
that that degenerates with extraordinary
rapidity have we as we've seen over and
over and over
so it's up to the it's up to the
centrists on both sides to
to deal with this i've been talking to a
lot of the optimist
rationalist types on my podcast matt
ridley and
bjorn lomberg and well in height and
pinker
more more distantly but more recently uh
lombergen
and ridley and and uh marion toopey who
who's written a lovely book on uh
human progress uh 10 things everyone
needs to know about
human progress it's something like that
huh anyways
one of the things we discussed
consistently was the difficulty
in promoting the message that all three
of these men are
very aware of which is that from a
material perspective
in terms of absolute privation
worldwide humanity is way better off on
virtually every dimension you could
possibly measure than ever and
and most of that improvement has
occurred in the last 40 years and it's
been revolutionary in its speed
and no one knows this
and so it's very important to know to
try to think through
why that is like that's such a positive
message now i talked to russell brandt
about this and i'm bringing him up for a
reason he's he's a lefty by temperament
and by heart and
his first objection but he's very
thoughtful and quick his first objection
you know i pointed out all this data
showing that by every possible
objective measure everything is way
better than it was
certainly a hundred years ago but
certainly even 20 years ago
even on the environmental front in the
main and he
said well what about disparity of
distribution so there's the problem of
absolute level of wealth let's say
that's improving but there is still
tremendous disparity
and of course that that is fair enough
you could even point out that
the role of the left is to provide a
conscientious voice for
for that's constantly attending to the
fact of continuing disparity regardless
of absolute level of wealth
and fair enough but but
having said all that it's a great
mystery that
incremental optimism is not sufficiently
motivating and you can't just wish human
nature is going to change it's not going
to change we got to tell a better story
and i also think that's why i'm a target
i think is because i am actually trying
to tell a better story and i'm actually
having some success with it
so i totally agree with that and and
that really does bring us to the book
because one of the things that folks
should know about
all of your books is that they are very
intimate very personal
you talk about yourself but you also
speak in in a way that most writers do
not you use
second person pronouns i mean you speak
directly to the reader you say
you feel this way you think this way and
a lot of people read they say i do think
that way this is a person who's speaking
directly to me in a way that
you know mainstream political books very
often do not they consider me sort of a
widget in whatever ideology they're
pushing or
or they they're considering the value of
systems or not systems
but you sort of end around that and i
think that in many ways that's what
members of the left find so so
threatening is because if you're a
member of the left and you believe
that all individuals are essentially
just the outgrowths of institutions
and therefore that all change by
individuals is going to be insufficient
and that it must be societal change that
that creates individual change
you're a threat because you're telling
people well you know the systems
can certainly get better but the main
threat to you is you
and that is a deeply threatening message
to people and if people find fulfillment
in that message
then the left really does have a problem
because if people start improving their
lives within the system
and not blaming the system for their
problems and instead
recognizing that that they can improve
their life that's what
members left tape most of all you know
you talk about in the book jordan the
fact that people are constantly coming
up to you and they're saying things like
you know i i was leading a dissolute
life
i read your book i started taking your
advice and i've turned it around and now
i'm doing much better in life
and you know i'm blessed to have much
the same experience from a lot of people
who listen to the show people who have
been homeless who now have graduated
harvard law school people
who were single moms and and then and
then decided to
to take a college course and and figure
out their lives people who have made
mistakes and turn their mistakes around
and to me those are inspirational
stories i think that because those
inspirational stories exist that i think
is why people find you to be such a
threat it's because so many people are
inspired by the stuff that you say
and change their life individually
without putting all of their iron focus
on a system that the left is mainly
focused on tearing down
i defy anyone to go read 10 000
comments on my youtube channels and not
come away
uh with a much better
with a much refreshed view of human
nature
the comments are in the main
unbelievably positive and not in the
naive sense they're
positive in a thoughtful sense and in a
communal sense because
the people who are making comments on
the lectures are also commenting on each
other and
there's ideological babble on both sides
i would say that's probably
five percent of the comments and uh
generally
i believe they're written by people who
didn't actually watch the lecture
because they're
often out of context but in any case 95
percent of the comments are
thoughtful but also extremely positive
which is very rare
in a social media comment landscape
which tends to be very very toxic
and so i think that's absolutely
great and it certainly has that impact
on me when i when i read it
um but then here's something else that i
i've observed in the media attacks
that have been directed towards me
they're not just directed towards me
they're well first they're directed to
who they think i
am so that's kind of interesting to
begin with but more than directed to me
and more perniciously is that they're
directed to
those who are hypothetically following
me now
i don't regard myself as someone with
followers i regard myself
as someone with viewers listeners and
readers
and that's different but in any case
my typical follower so goes the story is
a disaffected angry young white male
and for a while i
in some sense pushed back against that
and said well
my audience about 70 mail but youtube's
cues mail so
that's perhaps part of the reason and i
see no evidence that it's
particularly limited racially or
ethnically especially when i
watch see my lecture crowds and when i
meet people on the street but
but then i started to realize that that
was the wrong response the
right response is why does it
disturb you so much
that there's a group of people who by
your own admission are disaffected
and angry and alienated and young
and i'm helping them and why is that
exactly a problem
what is it that i'm supposed to be doing
with them just out of curiosity what do
you think
if you had your druthers would i ignore
them
would no one talk to them is that
actually what you want
well the answer seems quite clear that
that is exactly what's wanted that's
what's held forth
because there's this implicit assumption
in all of this critique
that in my very act of aid i'm doing
something
immoral immoral enough to be parodied
let's say is red skull
and so just what the hell is going on
here it's like why is that
now uh fodder for
for parody or slander precisely
i mean do you debate the fact that i'm
helping well you go read the comments
yourself and see what you think
and so then and then
i thought about that a bunch too i
thought well what is it
with with men the men that i'm speaking
to let's say um
why are they responding positively why
do they come to my lectures
the biblical lectures even which is very
surprising right because what the hell
are
men doing in a biblical lecture
especially young men especially when
they could go do
anything else and they have to pay for
it it's like what are they doing coming
to this lecture
well if the patriarchy is an evil
tyranny then the appropriate attitude
towards any male
ambition is to not treat it as ambition
but to treat it as
nascent drive to tyrannical power which
is certainly what
uh foucault would recommend for example
or dereda because it's all power
and so if you see some young man trying
to stand up and
better himself in any dimension you're
not going to trust that you're going to
identify that as
the manifestation of tyrannical power
and clearly if the patriarchy is a
malevolent
tyrant then any sign of the desire to
contribute it to it should be
at minimum not encouraged
but more subtly criticized and
discouraged at every possible
opportunity
and that's our culture if you enjoyed
this video be sure to hit the thumbs up
button and share it with all of your
friends